[Applause]
this is how Santa makes roofies hi
welcome to my home house record over to
watch my cartoon show what do you think
you are
I've been shown cartoons people for
about 13 years I just this is not your
home and and and I finally got you in
here I know I've been trying to get you
in here for first understand you don't
even you don't schedule these it's nice
to have you at my house did you did
Jimmy get you some some drink dude
there's not someone named Jimmy I want
to show you a cartoon called spinning
mice now see from that title it just
doesn't sound like it can go south no
it's pretty good it's it's in so the
director eventually was put in a mental
institution and the producer behind it
she was in the horses then advertising
it's a natural order they say that
horses are the gateway to ad sales the
person behind it was was hospitalized
the writer
no his cartoons were said to be quote
devoid of gags interesting well there's
only one way to find out Jimmy go ahead
nobody named Jimmy here Mike
Oh humans that is a human
that is not a human
is already creepin oh [ __ ] out he's
totally numb oh this kid Oh God
how are you a creepy yeah the only thing
that would make him creepier would be a
full-on heart everybody get out of there
now we have action what the hell is
going on is the prequel to billard which
is the prequel to Willard yeah something
tells me the animal rights people
weren't on set this day I am just so
lost Oh mice in the house who clearly
are losing their minds that kids like me
and you it's not at all this is
absolutely insane
no I have no problem declaring this to
be the craziest thing we've seen of
these I think I might have to leave I
don't feel good this is just a kid
talking to a cartoon mouse what's the
problem it's they were real nice a
moment ago so the kid dumped mice into a
little house that's right the mouse
became animated and now the mouse is
recollecting Louis the mouse is
explaining how and this is having
everything beautiful this is how Santa
makes roofies
Unity's might compete to find the
formula for change in ugliness so he's
making a cute formula it looks like
cooling right what does he choose it was
he got like caged deals o snakes
[Music]
oh boy well he turned them into doves
boy that's helpful
yeah we don't know what we're doing it
goes against their instincts you [ __ ]
us what's our next guy oh it's uh Oh
your horny toad
oh no that's not better what the [ __ ]
keep going wizard
I loves it let me talk about killing it
first time out of the gate yeah all
these animals like no oh now it's math
no it's definitely meth hey what
happened to the human children oh it's
not gonna go well [ __ ] yeah see
apparently they're and it's terrible
pain this is great
oh hey devil the second one of them gets
out and you are like I'm gonna kill
myself I can't handle this future get
him kill bad mother for supposed to be
on the side of the little man I think we
heart yes yes oh my god what if they
torment like any bearable part eating
him like piranhas I'm gonna go through
his notes
so they're making what they're making a
little little something now a little
potion they are it looks like they're
just getting shit-faced was no I mean
that's pretty cool
they said this was devoid of gags
[Laughter]
get in there
we're still gonna kill this guy
historical it's a slow process I mean do
we have any idea what they're making
what do you think I don't know clue
what's going on Jimmy he's not here oh
they're gonna put ya wizard Santa well
this is fair right yeah
[Music]
what is he gonna turn into oh boy look
guys I did one of them just go in his
anus oh yeah that I'm 80% one just went
in his bottom that's normal
where snakes what are they do they want
to be the snake they forget they're
gonna say oh they're gonna they're like
this is the serum recipe book or now
they're just okay the non labelled thing
you know what he is right now do you
know what he is got he's got a pain in
his bottom or maybe he's just loving
that part oh the demons
those are smart bird snakes
so I guess my biggest problem with this
is that in my made no but mice don't
just naturally run in circles like no
premise that's your that's your biggest
problem yeah the whole premise is it's
an interesting number one other than
that I'm fine
okay because that your problem there is
number 81 on my list yeah he learned a
lesson
leave well enough alone these are snakes
he can't so he finally came around come
on
oh wait that's a psychotic Mouse I mean
no that's just apps then you want okay
something absolutely insane sometimes we
had a cartoon with a moral lesson right
so that was just a question marks
sandwich with creep bread those two kid
bookends yeah great though let me finish
my sentences because no horrifying
horrifying now by horrifying do you mean
pretty cool no no the idea that that
would ever be shown to children children
would watch that and learn a lesson mind
your own business
yeah they'd like a lesson oh don't mix
cartoons and real film okay
oh yeah